c'était une belle soirée c'était une
très belle soirée tout le monde sur tous
les bancs venait saluer les efforts que
vous avez fait la qualité de votre
budget la manière dont vous aviez
défendu les artistes se venge taux
n'était pas le seul à dire combien nous
apprécions de tous les bords cela avait
été saluée on a un sujet et cela vient
de quasiment tous les bancs à part
monsieur barge tant aimé ce rambo qui
finalement ont trouvé kevin formidable
expérimentation assez curieuse dans
cette année 2020 ou était quasiment
impossible sera dans une salle de
spectacle dans une librairie et une
bibliothèque
je ne sais pas comment vous avez
expérimenté mais nous avions ce constat
je croise un ministre qu'il faut tout
simplement
après qu'on vous ait donné tant de
satisfécit écouter ici la voix du sénat
qui vous dit tout simplement et sans
monter la pression et sans exagération
aucune ça ne marche pas tirez en les
conclusions avant la ministre
bien je voulais apporter un certain
nombre d'éléments les chiffres que je
vous transmets sont bien sûr des
chiffres vérifiés vérifia je vous
apporte en temps réel les derniers
chiffres sur le pass culture et je m'en
porte la garante
je vais pas vous il a mené ici devant la
haute assemblée
des chiffres faux qui pourrait être
contredit donc je vous demande de me
faire confiance sur les chiffres à
défaut du reste ces chiffres sont vrais
premièrement une expérimentation de
trois ans sur le pass culture me paraît
pas être
délégitimer la l'ex que cette
expérimentation au contraire on comprend
que sur une opération aussi complexe de
comment dirais-je de conviction
d'utilisation en particulier avec des
publics qui pouvait ne pas être a priori
friands de ce genre de consommation une
expérimentation de trois ans ne me
paraît pas destiné à délégitimer le
processus bien au contraire
et ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'au
cours des trois ans la montée en charge
a été continue et la montée en charge a
été continue et c'est d'autant plus
remarquable que la dernière année
l'année 2020 a été particulièrement
marquée par une offre culturelle en très
grande difficulté donc cette montée en
charge
elle doit être salué alors maintenant
vous dites
certains ont dit alors qu'ils attendent
besoins qui ne sont pas satisfaits
pardon mais jamais vous avez été tout
sale salué dans cette assemblée
jamais les crédits de la culture et les
crédits du patrimoine n'ont été aussi
élevés
je rappelle quand même que sur plus de 4
milliards d'euros des crédits de la
culture le pass culture représente 59
millions d'euros
on peut pas dire qu'on a focalisé sur le
pass culture les crédits les crédits
destinés aux actions que vous avez salué
on est aux alentours de 1%
il n'y a pas un détournement des crédits
de la culture pour financer le pass
culture le jeu mais les chiffres en
comparaison les uns avec les autres
pardon alors vous avez dit on n'a pas pu
consommer de livres on n'a pas pu avoir
accès à certains puisque les livres sont
le principal objet physique a été acheté
alors moi je voudrais quand même redire
les faits qui sont là on a pu
here on a pu acheter des livres et je
voudrais en profiter pour faire un
certain nombre de commentaires sur aussi
bien les bibliothèques qui vont réouvrir
dans peu de temps mais surtout sur les
librairies
parce que les librairies pour des
raisons sanitaires ont été fermés mais
je tiens à saluer que les livres ont
continué à se vendre dans les librairies
grâce à des dispositions qui ont été
prises par le gouvernement sur les
opérations cliquer emporté j'ai visité
deux librairies une qui a réalisé 80% de
son chiffre d'affaires avec le système
click et emporter une autre qui a
réalisé 60% de son chiffre d'affaires
avec le système click et emporté les
librairies ont avant la période de
confinement réaliser des ventes
remarquables de livres qu'elles ont
toutes salué les chiffres d'affaires ont
augmenté de façon considérable dans les
librairies depuis la fin de la première
période de confinement c'est tout à fait
et il faut le saluer il faut s'en
réjouir
un libraire qui dans la semaine qui a
précédé le confinement envoyer 150
clients par jour en a bu six ans avec
des paniers moyens multiplié par deux ou
trois c'est tout à fait remarquable et
non je dis pas que tout va bien je dis
pas non mais je mange même des chiffres
des faits parce que dans les librairies
j'y vais je parle avec les libraires et
bien sûr c'est un crève coeur que de
voir des librairies fermé mais je dis
aussi que ces libraires ont pu continuer
à vendre a continué à les aider par le
prêt garanti par l'état par l'aide aux
salaires par des aides apportées par le
centre national du livre enfin à les
écouter les libraires et il vous dira
cela ils ont pas ils n'ont pas de raison
de me mentir pour me dresser de je ne
sais quel lauriers bien sûr on va
continuer on a continué à lire et ça moi
je mange m'en réjouis et je me réjouis
de voir que la première journée de
réouverture des librairies a été marquée
par des des consommateurs d'électeurs
qui se sont déployées en masse dans ces
lieux qui avant dans des lits
commerciaux sont des lieux de culture et
je voudrais que nous en réjouissons dieu
merci faut un petit peu d'optimisme
aussi il faut aussi surmonter cette
crise tous ensemble alors arrêtons
d'avoir des discours uniquement
misérabiliste dans ce domaine et aux
comptes et non mais oui et il faut lire
il faut lire il faut continuer à aller
dans la librairie
même ceux qui ont gueulé contre ceux qui
n'y ont jamais mis les pieds
[Musique]